>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Now hold onto the hand
of the person you came
with because it's time to
welcome Ronald L. Smith.
[ Applause ]
>> Ronald L. Smith: Hi, everybody.
Hi, guys. How are you?
She makes me sound really scary.
I'm scared of myself
after that introduction.
Well, you know what, this
is really quite fun for me.
I'm from Baltimore so I didn't have
to travel very far
to get here today.
And I like to go to a lot of schools
and do school visits and talk
to kids about writing
and scary books.
Well, they don't have
to be scary books.
I just like talking about books.
So this is a lot of fun for
me to see all you guys here.
I write scary books.
Who likes scary books?
Oh, my God.
Wow. I'm talking really scary books,
like you might want
to keep the lights on.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. Now I write what's
called middle grade.
So we know what middle
grade is, right.
That's like nine to twelve.
Nine to twelve year olds.
But I like to think of my books
for anybody can read them,
whether you're a little
kid or an adult.
The first book I wrote
was called, "Hoodoo",
and it's about this little boy
in Alabama a long, long time ago.
And a threat comes to his town.
It's a really bad guy called the
Stranger and he wears a black cloak,
and he has a black hat,
and he walks like this.
But anyway, the little kid in the
book, his name if Hoodoo Hatcher
and he's very special because he was
born into a family that uses magic
but he doesn't know how
to do any magic himself.
So this Stranger is
looking for Hoodoo Hatcher.
And Hoodoo has to find the magic
within himself to defeat
the Stranger.
It's a lot of fun.
So that book was my first book.
It was very exciting.
I was very happy to
see it published.
And my new book is called "The
Mesmerist" which you see up there.
And it's about a totally
different time and place.
It's in England at the
turn of the century, right.
So that's a long time ago,
over a hundred years ago.
And it's about a young girl and her
mom and they read people's minds
and they do seances and
they have Ouija boards.
But you know what?
It's all fake.
They can't really do it.
They're just taking
people's monies, money.
But then one day my
character, Jessamine,
she really does get a
message from the other side.
So even though she didn't
think that she could read minds
and do all this creepy stuff, she
actually can and something reaches
out to her and she finds
out that she's very special.
But before I wrote all these
books I was a little kid
and I lived all over the place.
My dad was in the Air Force.
We moved. I lived in Japan,
North Carolina, South Carolina,
Michigan, Alabama, Delaware.
But one thing that always kept me
from not losing my
mind was the library.
I knew that I could find
a good book in a library.
So libraries were really
what kept me feeling good.
So even though there was
always weird stuff going on,
and moving every two years,
the libraries were the
thing that I really loved.
And I started writing
books when I was young.
They weren't very good, just
lots of words on a page.
And then one day I grew up,
got a job, and I forgot all
about the magic of those
books I read when I was a kid.
I read books like "The Lord of the
Rings", has anybody heard of those?
And the Narnia books.
[Inaudible].
Actually, you know what,
I can speak Elvish.
You know the elves in
"The Lord of the Rings"?
Do you want to hear it?
>> Yeah.
>> Ronald L. Smith: Are you sure?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Okay.
Here goes.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Applause ]
Do you know what that means?
That means I got to
go to the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
No. It means "Three Rings for
the Elven-Kings under the sky,
Seven for the Dwarf-Lords
in their halls of stone."
You've heard it all before.
But anyway, that's what
you call being a nerd
and I like being a nerd.
I'm a grown up nerd.
And I like writing kids'
books because it reminds me
of how much fun I had reading
those books when I was a kid,
and how much fun I had memorizing
those words or Elvish and Klingon
or whatever you want to call it.
Now I get to do it for a living
and I really, really like it.
It's a lot of fun.
So I want to read just
a tiny bit of my book.
It won't take very long but
it will give you a sense
of what it's about, okay.
It will just be a page or two.
And this is from "The Mesmerist".
"England, 1864, a thousand
shards of porcelain.
Being stuffed into a wardrobe
with your hands tied is a
dreadful way to start your day.
There's hardly any light but for
the yellow glint of a candle flame
through a small crack in the door.
Dust tickles my nostrils.
Spiders are in the corners, too.
I hate spiders.
I breathe out through my nose and
try to think of something peaceful,
something besides Dr.
Barnes, sitting with Mother,
nervously clutching a
handkerchief or glass of sherry,
hoping beyond hope
that somehow a message
from his dead daughter,
Lydia, will be revealed.
That would be through me.
I am the vessel, you see, through
which the dead loved one will speak.
Actually it is all a sham.
This is how it works.
We knew Dr. Barnes had
lost his daughter recently
and when he made the appointment
all it took was a few flowery words
to begin the ruse.
"Dear Papa, dab your
eyes, dry your tears.
I am in the bosom of the Lord
in whose grace I have
found everlasting peace.
Yours always, Lydia."
What Dr. Barnes doesn't know is
that an hour before his arrival
I wrote this very message
on a chalk slate and hid it in
the wardrobe's secret panel.
From there it became a very
simple matter to step inside
with a blank one and make the swap.
Also, and this is key, Mother is
very good at tying slip knots.
Soft murmurs echo beyond the door.
I picture Mother with closed
eyes, her thin nostrils flaring.
On some days the flames from the
fireplace provide enough heat
for her face to flush, which makes
the act all the more authentic.
I hear the scrape of a
chair and then footsteps.
'Finally,' I sigh in relief.
I want to get out of here.
I pinch my cheeks for a rosy flush
and slip my hands back
into the knot.
The iron lock of the
wardrobe clicks.
The door squeaks open.
I take a deep breath, force
my body to go limp, and then,
with an exaggerated gasp, fall
face forward onto the floor.
[Inaudible].
Dr. Barnes leaps out of his chair.
I hear his teacup rattle
on the table
and then crash sending
a thousand shards
of porcelain across the hearth.
'Oh, my God,' he cries.
'Is she, is she dead?'
Mother, being a true professional,
plays her part with ease.
'No. She is fine.
She has been to the other side.
Please give her a moment.'
She kneels and leans in close and
brushes a lock of hair from my eyes.
The fresh scent of her
perfume surrounds me.
It is a lovely fragrance and one
I always associate with Mother
which lifts my spirits
whenever I am down,
something I feel at
this very moment.
She helps me up, unties the
thin rope that binds my wrists,
and leads me to a long chaise
covered in red and blue fabric.
Mother picks up the wooden
slate from the floor.
She gives Dr. Barnes a sharp look.
'The dead do not always speak
what we wish to hear,' she says,
'and sometimes their messages can be
confusing or even incomprehensible.'
Dr. Barnes exhales a shaky breath.
Mother unclasps the slate.
The blood drains from her face.
'What is it?'
Dr. Barnes asked, drawing closer.
Mother is speechless.
I sit up and read the words
written in a crooked script,
'Ring around the rosy, a pocket
full of posies, ashes, ashes,
we all fall down.'" [Inaudible].
So that's just the
beginning of the story.
[ Applause ]
Thanks. So basically there's a
really evil threat that's in town
and it's reaching out to
my character, Jessamine.
And she's going to
go on an adventure
and find out what it's all about.
So she has this power that
she didn't know that she had.
But like a lot of us,
we find that when we're
under pressure we can
sometimes rise to the occasion.
Does anybody have any
questions about writing?
Or drawing?
Or any kind of creative pursuit?
>> How long does it
take you to write books?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Well,
that's a good question.
You know, sometimes you can write a
book in a year or maybe six months,
but then you can continue to work
on it and it can a really long time.
So I'd probably say a year.
But the most important
thing is finishing the book
so it doesn't matter
how long it takes.
>> What made you want
to write scary books?
>> Ronald L. Smith:
That's a good question.
You know, I didn't really start
out wanting to write scary books
but for some reason when I
sat down that's what happened.
Maybe because I have
all this stuff hiding
in my brain and it wants to get out.
But I don't know for sure.
But it's fun.
I like it.
I like scaring people.
But I'm actually nice.
>> [Laughs].
Good to know.
>> What makes you [inaudible]
ideas of the books.
>> Ronald L. Smith:
Where do I get my ideas?
All around.
Sometimes you walk by and you
hear somebody on the street
and they may say something like a
few sentences or a couple of words.
Or sometimes you hear a song.
Or you might be on the train
and you hear something.
It's all around you.
All you have to do is
remember to look for it.
>> Where do you get the names?
>> Ronald L. Smith: How do
I get the name for my books?
Well, usually it has to
do with the characters
and what the story is about.
"Hoodoo" is called "Hoodoo"
because that's what it's
about which is hoodoo is a
sort of magic, a fold magic.
And "The Mesmerist" is called
"The Mesmerist" because it's
about mesmerizing people,
like hypnosis [inaudible].
So that's why it's
called "The Mesmerist".
Anybody else?
>> Are you books in a series?
Or are they just like random books?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Right now
they're just random books.
But I might write another one
with the same characters
sometime in the future.
And I didn't, I should tell you guys
something else that's really cool.
Next year in January there's
going to be a movie coming out.
It's called "Black Panther".
You've heard of that, right?
Well, I'm writing a book about
Black Panther as a little kid.
So that's going to
be really exciting.
So look for that book next year.
It's called "Black
Panther, the Young Prince".
>> How fun is it to write books?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Well, it's fun.
It's also hard and it's frustrating.
But it's fun.
You know why I say that is
because it's a great job to have
but you really, really have
to love it because it's hard.
You have to sit down and not get up.
You have to sit down and not
turn on, you know, Netflix.
You can't turn on "The Big
Friendly Giant" or "A Series
of Unfortunate Events" on Netflix.
You have to sit there and work.
So I try to reward myself.
If I work for two or three hours,
then I can watch something.
But it's fun.
I have to do it.
>> Where did you come up
with the idea for your book?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Well, these
two books are very different.
You know, I told you that
"Hoodoo" is about the deep South
in the 1930's, a long, long, long,
long, long, long, long time ago.
And that's where my
family's from, the South,
so I wanted to write
about the South.
And I also like things
like, things in England.
Like when I was a little kid the
fantasy books I read were all these
like British, English writers, so
I wanted to write a book like that.
Kind of like to remember
my childhood.
But that's where that came from.
>> How did you find your publisher?
>> Ronald L. Smith: How
did I find my publisher?
Well, that's a really long
story and you can go online
and you can find lots
of success stories.
But the short version is I
worked very hard for a number
of years on different stories.
"Hoodoo" was my third
book but it's the one
that got me signed by an agent.
So these days you can
publish books on your own
or you can find a traditional path.
I wanted to go the traditional route
so I kept working, and working,
and working until I wrote a book
that got an agent's attention.
And once it did, she
signed me as a client.
And then, you know, the
agents, they know editors.
So they send your book
to publishers.
And I got really lucky.
It was a dream come true because
"Hoodoo" as my first book went
to auction so several
people wanted to buy it.
So I was very lucky.
>> Why did you like
drawing the pictures?
>> Ronald L. Smith: What's that?
>> Why did you like
drawing the pictures?
>> Ronald L. Smith:
Well, I didn't get
to draw the pictures in my books.
The people who make the
book, the book company,
they choose people
to draw the pictures.
So my books are mostly words.
Sometimes at the beginning
of the chapter you might
see a little picture
or the cover, like, has a picture.
But the writer usually
just writes the words.
Okay.
>> Hi. How and why did you decide
to pursue a career in writing?
And what kept you going?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Well,
that's a very good question.
Well, from the time I was
your age I liked to write.
I used to do the writing and my
brother used to do the drawings.
So I would write and he would draw.
And we would stay up
late creating stories.
We stayed up so late my mom
and dad would bang on the door
and tell us to go to sleep.
So that's a pretty
good problem to have.
But I like it so much
I just kept doing it.
And then when I grew
up, I looked for a job
where I could use my writing skills
and that job was advertising.
So I used to write commercials that
you've probably seen on TV before
like McDonald's and a
bunch of other stuff.
But I got tired of writing that kind
of stuff so I really kept working
on my books that whole time
and it finally paid off.
But if you like to write,
find as many opportunities
as you can to write.
Whether it's for your school paper,
or for yourself, or your friends,
or whatever, just continue to do it.
>> Thank you.
>> Ronald L. Smith: You're welcome.
>> How do you choose
your characters?
>> Ronald L. Smith: How do I what?
>> How do you choose
your characters?
>> Ronald L. Smith: They choose you.
The character chooses you.
They come around and they
tap you on the shoulder.
And then you turn around
and they're gone.
But they whisper in your ear
what their name is sometimes.
So that's a very kind of weird
way of saying you just make it up.
You know? Sometimes you say, "I want
to write about this kind of person,"
or, "I want to write about
that kind of person."
And they just kind of begin
to take a picture in your mind
and you just put it all together
and then they become a real person,
at least in your head, sometimes.
And then you can also talk to them
and people will think you're crazy
but I talk to my characters
all the time.
>> How tiring is it to write a book?
>> Ronald L. Smith: It's
a lot of work, yeah.
It's a lot of work.
It's very tiring.
But it's worth it if you finish it.
If you can get to the end,
then it's really worth it.
>> How do you separate, how do
you know when to write dialog,
then when to write narrative?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Wow.
So you've got all the right
words, dialog, narrative, plot.
Yeah. That's great.
Well, you know, when you look
at any book in the bookstore
or the library, you're
going to see dialog
and you're going to
see the narrative.
And you'll see that it's broken up.
So you can't have a book
that's all dialog, right.
You can't have a book
that's all description.
So you have to find those places
where your characters talk.
So you want to set the
scene and then you want
to say one person says one thing.
Another person says another thing.
So it becomes natural because
you can't go on, and on,
and on describing a car, right?
You got to describe the
people in the car, too.
And they're probably going to
talk so that's how you do it.
>> Do you ever write
books for four year olds?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Before?
Did I ever write books before?
>> For four year olds?
>> Ronald L. Smith: Oh.
Maybe one day.
That's got, I think
that's really hard.
But there are lots of good
books for four year olds though.
Okay. Any more?
>> How many books have you written?
>> Ronald L. Smith:
I've written two books.
Well, I've actually
written a lot of books
but I've only written two
books you can find in the store
because the other ones are under
my bed because they're really bad.
>> [Laughs].
>> Ronald L. Smith: And I don't
want anybody to read them.
>> Did you ever do any scary
thing when you were little?
>> Ronald L. Smith:
Oh, my God, did I.
>> [Laughs].
>> Ronald L. Smith:
I can't tell you.
They're really scary.
>> Tell me, please.
>> Ronald L. Smith:
I was kind of bad.
One time I rode my
bike down the hill
because somebody dared
me to and I broke my arm.
So don't ever do that.
Do what your mom and
dad tell you to do.
>> All right.
I will.
>> Ronald L. Smith: Last question.
>> How much did your book cost?
>> Ronald L. Smith:
How much does it cost?
Well, if you go right over to -- .
I don't know actually.
Well, the "Hoodoo" just
came out in paperback
so it's not that expensive.
And "The Mesmerist"
is still in hardback.
So they're selling them over there
at the Politics and Prose booth.
So thanks very much for
coming out, everybody,
and listening to me
ramble on, and on, and on.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.